all the members and all the executive
members are here tonight and all the
officers to our second virtual meeting
of the suffered pandemic or which we
call overview and scrutiny committee and
can I just remind everyone this meeting
is being broadcast live and will be
available after the meeting by the
council's YouTube channel and can
members and officers please remember use
the raise hand feature which is on the
bar and can you mute your microphone
when you're not speaking and if if
you're struggling with your internet
connection and turning your camera off
may help just for a while
it's nothing to do with your facing by
the way right well we have two main
items tonight on the agenda that members
are very interested in executive members
and officers have been asked to provide
a verbal update and committee members
were asked to provide questions in
advance in order to help to frame the
response to the committee however there
is a large number of questions and that
have been received some quite technical
in their nature which given the time
available at tonight's meeting and the
demands on the service in responding to
the pandemic meant it may not be
possible to cover everything in detail
officers will cover as much as they
reasonably can do in the time available
and where appropriate a more detailed
response can be given outside of the
meeting if that is required and I think
you know for the smooth running of the
meeting we hope that we can get through
all of the items and the questions have
been asked so with that kind of
introduction the first item on the
agenda is attendance and listed to note
the attendance including officers and
any apologies for absence we have
received one apology and that's from
counselors sure other any other
apologies no other apologies have been
received yeah thank you
item two are the minutes and it's two
minutes of the last meeting on the 27th
of May can we agree to note those
minutes everybody happy yep it's sort of
day I'll take that as a read sorry David
yes I could I couldn't find the raise
hand icon quick enough I do apologize I
think my name is actually missing from
those presents at the last meeting so
with that trustee change pleased yeah
that's fine John make sure that that
happens
item threes declarations of interest
does anybody wish to declare any
interest the items on the agenda no item
four is urgent business that I haven't
received any so item 5 is questions from
the public and again I have haven't
received any questions from the public
item 6 is a post and pre decision
scrutiny and you've all seen what
decisions have been made by the
executive these items are for noting and
if any committee member wished to
receive additional information on any of
these items they could ask at the
meeting or either receive answers via
email or it could be considered at other
future other future agenda item so has
anybody got anything to raid in
in relation to item six not seeing
anybody
so again these are just for noting so
thank you for that so we're going to do
meet really of the agenda and the first
of those is item seven Health and Social
Care and I suggest in terms of timings
but for this and the next item at eight
will of time around about 50 minutes
hope to fifty minutes actually so if we
can do it a little bit sooner that will
benefit beneficial for us to sort of at
the end have you know 10 15 20 minutes
to discuss some of the things that we've
heard within the meeting there will be
obviously you'll have some questions
relating to some of the answers that we
get to the questions that we've asked so
you know I'll try and move move it quite
quickly as quickly as we can some of the
issues are very complex so yeah if
there's any additional information that
could be asked at the meeting and either
receive answers by email as well so oh
no that's
yeah so it's only going to health and
social care I think but for health and
care in attendance we have counselors
later the executive member for health
and well-being and equality's and Alan
Ellen a Ralph Ralph director of public
health so I don't know who's going to
speak first councillor Slater
didn't you thanks Dave and we've
received some quite in-depth questions
and Eleanor has been pulling together
some written answers for us that we'll
be able to sit along and
once they have been from this meeting
must have been agreed and finalized but
if there's anything within there because
there are quite a few topics if it was
anything in there that people would like
to us to give answers on and this
evening we're more than happy to do that
obviously I know that there is some
really and keen priority around mental
health obviously the impact of Coe bid
on Thames community and I think that
people may be keen to understand what a
trap trace and test or trace and track
and that's ok ok I get those three Vic's
took quite often and and what what that
will look like in Catholic going forward
so if there are any specifics that the
committee would like to my scores were
more than happy to to respond to any any
questions and this evening but like I
said Allah has been working with other
offices and across
jimsy mhh around mental health and with
with some partners in Greater Manchester
to get some answers together and for us
so if you like if you've got any
questions at a specific that we can sort
of deal with tonight and more than happy
to well I think and I'll just bring in
in terms of the questions that we've
asked I think some actually relate to
the public health and some relate to the
social social care and we do have
councillor Harding and you know the
executive mender member for adult
services and Diane Eaton who is a
corporate director about services and I
think you know we've kind of lumped
those two together but but the the
questions that we asked with around
mental health and the CQC rapport
regarding learning difficulties and
autistic spectrum disorder and I members
to the care act and I think
what members are also interested in is
the test track and isolate so they were
the point that we wanted to really bring
out in tonight's meeting so I don't know
who wants to kick off in relation to him
I could I think a lot of the mental
health questions tie into the answers
that Diane Eaton will be giving and
similarly with the learning disability
so if I run through some of the issues
regarding the main population and also
the race and then if I am leads on the
mental health and learning disabilities
with that yeah if I if I start with the
questions we were asked and then if
people have other questions I'm happy to
either answer them or take them about
the disparities and the risk and
outcomes for forbid nineteen among our
main population yeah and whether this
situation in Greater Manchester is the
same as the national situation where
we've seen far more deaths in people
from black black and Bangladeshi and
Pakistani origins than from the white
population so it's difficult to get
because so we're having to do some work
to look back to see if we can match the
data that we have on the deaths with
other pieces of information to make sure
whether they're whether that has
happened what we've done is an interim
is that we mention a piece of work on an
inequality and ethnicity inequalities
but also deprivation is a big risk
factor for data from code that nineteen
as is underlying health conditions
particularly diabetes and high blood
pressure so what we've done is there's a
Greater Manchester paper has been done
and it is clear that the picture seems
to be similar in Greater Manchester as
the national picture and we have also
been
looking at the deaths in Trafford and
because we don't have the full details
on ethnicity what we've done is map the
deaths we've got against the population
profiles by Ward out of different
ethnicities and I would have to say
we've got no reason national highly
likely that the national picture has
also been played out in Trafford so the
second question was what extra steps are
being taken to protect the vulnerable
these vulnerable groups so what we've
been doing is trying to make sure that
we are set the services we provide and
particularly the access to testing and
treatments are being properly followed
through because one of the other things
that you'll be aware of is that we've
seen in excess death people from coded
19 but also from people from other
conditions possibly because people
aren't accessing health services in a
timely manner so we're wanting to make
sure that we look at all the deaths
rather than the coded 19 and working as
part of Greater Manchester strategy for
increasing the amount of people tested
we've been also working with some of the
community groups in how the messaging
about and what support people need in
order to access testing and to relay
people's fears about the best
and finally our community hubs have been
hugely powerful and very very effective
in reaching our population different
populations across Trafford and we'll be
looking at how that goes forwards and
how we make sure that our community hubs
are accessible to all of our populations
and that they're providing the support
that people need in a timely manner and
also are being designed with what's been
fantastic the community hubs is that
co.design element with our communities
to make sure that those communities are
really key to making sure that the
services that are being provided are
designed and delivered in a way that
suits those communities thanks for that
does anybody have any questions on the
bane
from what Helena said any color track
and trace of the mental health I'll
stick with the public health track and
trace if that's okay with the mental
health well I'll come in after by own if
that's okay we got asked and what what
progress has been made with the test
track and trace an isolate system what's
travelers involvement so nationally you
know that you will know that the
national system went live on the 28th of
May and the national system has is
expecting to deal with the red 80% of
contacts of confirmed cases the red 80%
of the confirmed cases will be dealt
with through a national system of
telephone calls from that national team
and then about 20 the cases will get
escalated to Greater Manchester in our
case and those cases are cases where
there are more complex of these about
the case so it might be about the
individual characteristics with the case
that might be a population for example
of people that like rough sleepers who
may not have access to web-based systems
for contacting or where people might not
be so keen to engage with telephone
based systems or it might be weathers
and there's other risks around the
setting so a high consequence setting or
a high risk setting and we'd include
schools or care homes in those settings
where we really do want to be able to
understand what the implications for
that setting is so though in systems
come through to the Greater Manchester
theme and the great images that went
live last Monday it's still I would say
those still teething problems as you'd
expect both in the communication from
the data that comes from the central
system integrator Manchester is still
being developed and and still needs
tightening up so there
but the idea that the other issue we
have is obviously locally we often hear
about a test before the confirmed
positive comes through so we'll often
hear about suspected cases in the care
home or in a school before the testing
is done so we hear quite often before
all the locals there's anything about it
so quite often we have already started
pieces of work with those settings to
make sure that we've got everything in
place in case somebody comes back
positive
so it's only days but I'm really I'm
really young but we're getting we're
getting a lot more input I would say
absolute allathee into the design of the
systems and we have previously so early
days if it's it's on its way how many
have been tracked and traced you know in
in shock again and in Greater Manchester
so in Greater Manchester I'm not sure
but in trust that we have had because of
bounce so at the on Friday and I should
have looked me do I can go and look now
but we had we've had over a hundred
since the national system went live
which was at the end of May and 25 of
those have been escalated up to Greater
Manchester but most most of those health
care workers or people in care homes
those have been the biggest two biggest
groups of people that have been
escalated up to us and then we have got
some we've got a couple of we've got
some ongoing work with care homes and
schools that we're waiting for results
from okay Kay Karen Catherine thank you
chairman thank you for that feedback on
the test track and isolate I've just got
a couple of questions really and first
of all how long is it now taking for
test results to be returned because
this is really crucial isn't it in terms
of that whole system operating
efficiently and effectively and also of
the people that you've been asked to
contact um you know what percentage of
people have been isolated as a result of
the kind of contact tracing and are we
actually monitoring because obviously
it's one thing saying something over the
phone yes you know and isolate but what
are we doing in terms of trying to make
sure that that happens
and are we giving people who are
isolating any support so it's another
thing to say you know you were isolate
but then what happens if you need you
know financial support you're shopping
or things like that so and and also it
could have just have kind of an
impression of how effects if you think
the system is operating the mo me so
that you think it's got a way to improve
I mean how I mean I think we will be
totally Goosby will standard I mean just
how how far away from it is it at the
moment thank you so we are still away
from the world standard they have to say
how long via the MFT labs the mistress
the labs with the foundation trust those
we're guessing back very quickly within
24 hours that part of it I'm not at all
worried about and health care workers
and some other groups are particularly
high risk groups so they will be the
ones where we've sent out our
communities swabbing to you and we get
those results back within 24 hours and
we're all quite comfortable with the
with the responsiveness of the national
system isn't working as smoothly yet and
it does still seem to be I think it is
improving with on Friday for the first
time and I was very we actually got the
pillar to date on the national system
that was the first time I actually had
any in all of the times of affinity
routes being running which was middle of
May
we are now getting that data through in
terms of the responsiveness at the
moment I get data on how many people
have been contact traced but not the
results of that and not whether people
are self isolating so I don't get their
data at the moment at that level of
granularity I don't know it's Greater
Manchester is getting that yet as I said
the Greater Manchester system only went
live on Monday so they really haven't
they're only just starting doing any so
we will be reliant on the National Data
which so I imagine the data that we get
to traffic this is what you will have
heard at the press over the weekend and
that level of compliance and I'm hoping
that once we get to the particularly
with the healthcare workers with and
with our local high consequence
isolation because we're doing so much
work with those things we're really
engaging with them about why they needs
to self that way their workers need to
self isolates and so on there are much
more confidence that with a lot of those
settings we are getting very good
compliance so you know it is in its
early days and we are trying to make
sure that in terms of the support to
people when I'm on when our self
isolating I think that's going to be an
increasing issue and it's one that needs
to be brought up nationally and and
regionally because at the moment well
people are ferno's or where people are
able to you know there's people are
working from home it's not so difficult
for people so self isolate as the
economy starts going again I think it's
going to be increasingly difficult
particularly for our low in low low paid
residents to be able to engage
effectively with that and again this
means one of the things we will be
looking at is the uptake of testing
around the borough by geography and by
communities so that we can try and do
some work if we think that some
populations subpopulations aren't
accessing testing it will be a question
of trying to do some work with those
populations to try and think about how
can be encouraged to go for testing if
they're symptomatic and what support
they need again this comes back to the
conversations about the community helps
as well but it's it's a very big problem
for us and especially as this could be
going on for 18 months and it won't be
you know it's when everybody is is self
isolating if you like it's one thing
that if it's just your household it
becomes a very different matter so it's
really important that we have really
good plans in place and that our
communities are engaged in the designing
of those plans because it's you have to
be prepared to do this it's going to be
a long slog for all of us I think and
you can't do this to people you have to
do this with people thank you
so in terms of the data that we collect
through the track and trace arrangements
is it sensitive enough to draw or look
for correlations between you know the
tracking and the tracing and phases of
the walking or the lifting of the of the
lockdown so those various phases schools
for example last week secondary schools
today you know in terms of the detailed
information was collected do you know is
that kind of correlation it hasn't been
possible up to now because I've just
been guessing data fit well I've been
getting traffic for the I've been
getting traffic data for Trafford and
for pillar 2 until Friday I haven't been
getting anything but it will be able to
be broken down at more locality level so
we'll be neighborhood level so we'll be
able to start following some the better
we will also have also us to make sure
that we can get information about the
setting and so you know whether it's
linked to a business or whether it's
cavern or a school or so so that we can
follow that up what we're hoping is to
be able to pick up by doing a really
thorough testing program
we'll be able to pick up cases early
rather than the previous systems which
was really waiting for people to be ill
enough for enough people to be ill
enough that they were getting
hospitalized which obviously is about a
week or two after the infection so we're
really trying to get this data as some
council about Lee says getting the bit
getting the test results quickly and
getting it on that and geographical
basis will be a we'll be able to use
that to really understand what's going
in a population and we're still waiting
for that data but we have been promised
it counselor barking Thank You Joan so
just another quick well thank you so
much on that for explaining right
because I just asked and given that GPS
may be aware of infections perhaps
before and overcome at the national
system is informed I mean are we trying
to draw GPS into the process and using
their local knowledge and expertise as
well we are but a lot of people have
been encouraged not to go to their GP
for coded related matters with some PC
we didn't want the spread of infection
through there
but what we can do now and we again as a
Friday I started getting data from the
one-one-one system of how many calls are
being made to 1 1 1 so that would give
us a really good idea of what's going on
in our in our area because actually most
people went in particularly to book a
test for doing that through the
one-one-one system and the fact that
people ring up and ask about tests as
well gives you an idea of what's going
on in in the city in their community if
people are starting to have our IDs and
therefore booking or enquiring so we're
using that system we will now be able to
use that system as well councillor
clogging thanks Ann thanks down there
for the update and demand and then I can
see the vast amount of work that has
gone into this across all of GM I'm just
wondering on the bigger picture level if
we're learning from elsewhere so it
sounds like GM is doing is doing well
here and but this place is like said
Korea that have been doing this for
months
are there conversations going on at some
level because I mean
Trafford level but somewhere along the
way saying look these people were the
early adaptors we can learn from their
mistakes we can copy the best bits and
get something up and running really
quickly so and I think well not be I
mean that's been going on all the way
through and I think one of the big
learning things from this is that a lot
of Asian countries that I've had
experience formers well and particularly
from SARS and so the population was much
more alert to all of this cells
obviously had a much higher death rate
and was more serious illness than coded
19 but it was also easier to contain
because it was more serious so you
didn't have the asymptomatic the number
of asymptomatic people and the that
route of transmission and also you
didn't have as much pre-symptomatic
transmission so I think the populations
in Taiwan in South Korea in Singapore
Malaysia Thailand they were already much
more alert to what you have to do and
the or and nationally the government's
are also much more aware of what what
you need to do in these situations I
think in Europe we've had such a long
time without without needing to do
anything like this that we have actually
been caught on the hop us Italy Spain
France particularly so there's there's
all sorts of reasons behind that but we
are definitely behind as the death rates
okay
Slater did you want to just come in on
this helpful Hawkins was making around
living in lessons from other countries
around the world
you know hopefully we are doing that
modest Ombuds in taiwan and it's still
only had seven deaths the onset of Kovac
and where he lives there are only
actually 88 miles away from and we've
have I know there's water in between but
it's not you know it's not very far and
they in Taiwan they have a population
the same size as Australia though you
know the
Tracy which we started to do initially
at the very beginning of this and
pandemic I think that we know we we
tracked and traced a couple of people
who've been to northern Italy skiing and
you know those people were isolated
quite early doors in traffic but then
you know there was a decision to stop
doing tracking and tracing but tracking
and tracing has stopped
lockdown in our country so you know we
need to be this needs to be the way the
way forward for us so I think the work
that Ellen is doing and some of the
information that we'll have for you on
another you know and other meeting going
forward I think you know you you'll see
that actually tracking and tracing does
work so pretty much share that was all I
needed to say they I think the the other
things I would just add for the benefit
to scrutiny the track and trace will
work but it only works if you've got
enough in sufficient numbers of cases in
the population to make tracking and
tracing worthwhile if you follow me if
you get too many cases you're back down
to lock down and the way that we can
stop it spreading is by really
maintaining good respiratory hygiene the
good hand hygiene and absolutely that
physical distancing and making sure that
we stay those two meters away from
people and I think especially for
businesses coming back we really need to
be supporting our businesses to
understand the importance of their
workers
keeping seeing that distance from each
other and being able to do that because
without that you could quite easily get
a whole business suddenly discovering
there's a case and your whole business
is closed 14 games because other people
with contacts and needing to self
isolate so it is really important but at
the moment we don't think I can place
we'll do this on our own
we have to be taking absolute ownership
of our responsibility for our lives and
making sure that we don't inadvertently
spread the disease or put ourselves in
danger of catching it so again it's
those it's they're saying messages about
the two meters don't see too many people
stay out don't doors wherever you can
much less spread outdoors and make sure
you wash your hands
Thanks councillor Barker wanted to just
come back in briefly
thank you very much oh just a real quick
question for and thank you again and I
could you just say well let us know how
many people are actually within the
council tracking I'm trading what size
is the team and does the team feel
overwhelmed right now they're too many
cases to do all the tracking and trace
you need to do or do you feel there's
just about the right balance
thank you so the way it's being
organized in Greater Manchester is that
the tracking and tracing team most the
contact tracing is being done by the
public health England in the Greater
Manchester team and then we get we get
involved in the local hard cases and we
will be work so what we're doing at the
moment is with my colleague hello you
know my colleagues Helen Collins and
Donna sago who I think members of the
committee will know Donna is leading on
contact tracing and we're just setting
up the program at the moment for how
we're going to make sure that if we do
get cases in high consequence settings
or settings where we need actually send
somebody out so that might be with say a
drug alcohol service users or avila
communities who will do the contact
tracing in those cases and so we're
looking at for example with our traveler
communities we know our visitors have
really good compilation ships with those
communities they will probably be
talking to the health physicist about
how they do the contact tracing in that
in that situation suddenly our drugs and
alcohol service workers etc so in terms
of us locally what we're doing locally
is setting up the program management of
all of that the framing that linking in
with the Greater Manchester system we've
had some national funding to support
this and we have put forward a program
plan of the number of people that we
think need to work in Trafford to help
support the program that will include
for example communication support this
won't all be public health people not
only because it needs to be spread
across the council because of all the
different skills and all the different
parts of the council that this will
affect but also if you imagine trying to
spread that you know most public health
people in the country already employed
doing well you know all my retired
colleagues are all back
working at public health England so we
are we are going to be spreading this
around the different parts of the
council so that we have we have we are
getting funding into the council to help
us supportive is that it's with that
okay thanks very much
I wouldn't know for that I've got no
other questions on that so if we go back
to the mental health and you know I
think you were sort of saying that this
comes under Diane Eaton and Joanne
Harding mostly there just to say on the
mental health it's the the question a
lot of the questions specifically about
the services but one of our concerns
obviously from a public health
perspective is the impact that that
nineteen is having on our population
especially the impact of isolation on
our children and young people and their
education prospects but also that they
associate the impact of social isolation
on teenagers being particularly negative
so trying to make sure that they you
know we have been working hard to try
and make sure that our young people are
properly supported yeah okay so okay
thanks very much other news it's been
very helpful can can we just move on
then to social care and I don't know how
you want to take this Joanne and Diane
he should we start on the mental health
and then there are the CQC's report
regarding learning difficulties and
autistic spectrum disorder and
amendments to the Care Care Act yeah I
think those are the the main ones
yeah so I don't know who wants to start
councillor Harding more yeah I'm very
happy to she starts chair
do you want me to start with the
easements to the care acting really a
challenge which ones are you going into
going to start with the easements to the
Care Act first of all and obviously I'll
bring diet diamine potentially on some
areas if there are any gaps the toppers
have left really so so you all be aware
that we work adult social care works
under the framework of the Care Act and
there were some easements made to the
Care Act from the 31st of March in order
to be able to respond to the Kovich
pandemic I think some other things to
say really about why the easements came
into force really was about allowing
councils to manage the pressures that
they found themselves under as a result
you know the impact on on social care
and to be able to prioritize how we
resource and target our interventions
around social care I think the thing to
say at the very beginning and I know
that the word unprecedented is used a
lot but I want to stress just clearly
how difficult these times have been for
staff working in health and social care
so I think that means recognizing right
from the very beginning and the impact
that this pandemic has had on all
services across health and social care
really so those easements came into
effect from the 31st of March and what
we have seen actually is a really true
integration between health and social
care as a result what was really pulling
and working together over the last 10 to
12 weeks really some of the changes that
have been brought into force means that
councils will not have the duty like
they used to having the path to assess
to do very detailed assessments they
won't have been having to do financial
assessments and some of the
responsibilities to carers it's a duty
to provide as opposed to some of the
powers really a power to me as opposed
to duty so what that has allowed us to
do with some of these
so and just to say that traffic has not
moved from stage one of those easements
so really for us in a lot in many ways
it is business as usual but one of the
things that has happened as a result of
the easements is that you will know that
traffic has historically been an outlier
in relation to our delay transfers of
care with people being in hospital when
they haven't needed to be at times
because we haven't been able to get
people out to the right kind of
placements one of the things that
Trafford has put in place is the
provision of discharge to assess
capacity so that has meant that we've
had beds for people to go to where
they've been able to be discharged from
hospitals safely to another setting
which has allowed us to carry out some
more detailed assessments of needs until
we can consider what the next
destination will be for that person
buried in mind that the person should
always have a degree of choice in where
they want and are able to go so whether
that means we discharge somebody safely
to home with a package of care or
whether they eventually are discharged
to a pair or nursing home but that
discharge to assess facility has enabled
us to move people very quickly out of
hospitals and that's absolutely been the
right thing because it's allowed us to
have capacity of hospital beds which
we've needed those beds in case we did
see you know increased admissions of
people with Tobit so the other thing
just to say is that it is time limited
and there is a process of checks and
balances for the easement of Care Act so
what that means is we haven't moved we
haven't had to progress and we haven't
had to change a lot but one of the
things that would become an issue would
be for example around staffing if we
didn't have the stuffing as a resource
to be able to carry out some of our
business as usual that we might need to
change and move to the next step of
easements but at any chair that would at
any step where there are changes needed
so Diane as the director of adult social
services and Gemma Brown is the
principle social worker would need to
involve me as the
remember for social care about any
changes that are made as changes
progress then things that the health and
well-being board could be involved the
NP would be involved so there are there
are checks and balances when decisions
has to be made as if we need you to
progress throughout the easements so I
just wanted to give you some assurance
is that there are checks and balances if
we need to do that readiness so I hope
that answers some of you questions
around the easements yeah I mean I think
yeah I think it does we all we members
of the committee had the reports from
the last well-being board meeting and
the video was obviously this topic was
brought up at that meeting and so that
prompted the question and some of the
other questions as well I think what we
would like to know if if if you decide
depending on circumstances that you have
to go down the route of you know making
changes and relaxing the services then I
think you know scrutiny would need to
know about that and because I think it
would be you know if you had to make
some you know quite desperate changes
and you know that would impact severely
on some of our most vulnerable residents
so I think that's the reason I would
yeah could I ask a question I'm sorry
I'm not on the the system for the
council I've had to use my father
yeah okay and those easements are in
place from for approximately two years
is that correct and the other question
that I want to ask it's nice to hear
that there is
when haven't been able to do assessments
we are doing
should be balanced okay yeah okay can we
move on to the other question I'm gonna
have to move a bit bit quick and sorry
about that but we do have a lot to get
through so the CQC report regarding
learning difficulties and autistic
spectrum disorder okay so he's
specifically asked a question about
traffic yeah around this so one of the
things that again just to identify that
of course in general people who are
living with learning disability do
generally fall into a high-risk group of
individuals that may be at a higher risk
and underlying health conditions as well
so that is that is already recognized
and known so what have we done we've
done lots of work around shielding those
people that will pretend to will
potentially be at higher risk and we've
made sure that some of the supportive
living accommodation one of the things
that has happened is being that there's
been restrictions placed on people who
can visit some of those settings which
it's a double-edged sword really because
if you place restrictions and that
obviously means that sometimes people
don't have access to family and friends
that they would ordinarily see but also
if you do that it minimizes the risk of
the amount of people that are coming in
and out alike we've a lots of our
settings really one of the things I have
I screech need to recognize is the work
that staff have done around our care
settings in some of our care homes staff
have actually moved into those settings
to minimize the risk to some of those
residents so I think some of those
things have been put in place to make
sure that we we minimize risk the day
services that we would ordinarily
provide for people have had to close as
a result of making sure that there's
isolation and infection control and
again that is a double-edged sword
because I think it's important to
recognize the incredible pressure that
has been placed on
Chara's because that means we don't have
the rest bike facilities available that
we would that we used to have that we do
actually have a respite facility in
Trafford if there's if there's an
emergency and an urgent need we do have
capacity to provide respite for families
who are supporting somebody with with
learning disability and autism so but it
goes to Diane's wider point as well
really some of the risks that come into
play is around our staffing so if we do
have staff that test positive or they've
been in contact with somebody that there
needs to self isolate it puts the
further pressure on those services that
we provide for learning disability Diane
I'll leave you two to pick up the
question on uncounted numbers specific
for Trafford just to say as well staff
and people in those settings have got
exactly the same access to things like
PPE infection control training the same
level of support that our care homes
have had all of that has been provided
across our learning disability support
services - but I'll hand over to Diane
to pick up some of the areas that I
haven't quite answered this is a very
very sensitive issue we have had five
deaths reported in disabilities over
March and April that's not necessarily
higher than normal we do is a review of
issues so we obviously advise through
public health and through out through to
the providers has been key and
also their financial support to them
before and they have been absolutely
amazing providers yeah are there any
questions
councillor Harding into that yeah I mean
I think just to say it
it is very CQC has raised it and I think
he probably sent alarm bells ringing but
what you've told it I think some
reassurance so thanks thank you for that
I've got question from councillor hold
Holden and but it's about testing so I
don't know what it was job do you want
to leave that till later when we can
very short a very simple I think I go on
then going back to this discharge to
assess right after some of the national
criticisms well discharge from hospital
into the care system
Joe and we have an agreement set up from
mid March with everybody who is
discharged from Manchester foundation
trust they were before discharge into
the dish assess I bet no just his
government he Tyler Noel which reminds
me you know you can catch it after
you've undermined the need isolate
people on arrival into the high
interesting we're now also have people
living at home
and that about it for people with
disabilities well because obviously
people okay and I think the only other
thing that we wanted to sort of raise
with you was about the mental health so
in relation to adult mental health
services they are operating as as usual
and they have what we call a daily
sitrep situation report which is where
we are daily reviewing referrals and
people that we have as inpatients
particularly if we're looking to
discharge something into the community
what that package of pear looks like to
make sure that strengthened as much as
possible the big area of concern that
we've had throughout all of this is is
to be able to manage those face-to-face
contacts with people when we are
supposed to be trying to self isolate
minimize risk and so on but again that's
stuff having access to PPE equipment
infection control training all of those
things are in place for our mental
health practitioners and staff so
there's help lines across Greater
Manchester for people that are already
known to services - and there have been
new helpline set up for people that
aren't known to services and that aren't
engaged in services so there's a crisis
number called shout which is available
for people that feel they're in
immediate crisis of course the
Samaritans that's available 24/7 and we
will obviously have to pick off and do
some detailed work post Ovid because I'm
absolutely certain we are going to see
evidence of trauma grief bereavement
after this some of the work that I've
been doing with care home providers I
was speaking to them last week and the
stories that they recounted to me were
absolutely devastating really some of
the things that they have witnessed but
the way they have stepped off has been
incredible but believe me there will be
a trauma
impact when when we when we get through
this it might not be a week down the
line it might be months down the line
but people will absolutely be adversely
affected by some of the situations they
have had to deal with the Mental Health
Transformation Board is being in the
process of reestablished being we
established where we look to try and
shift some of the conversation away from
crisis management to look at prevention
to how do we keep our community as well
how do we focus on living well at home
so we can really start to build those
healthy communities the hopes have been
mentioned that's the model that we want
to build on that voluntary and community
sector offer that we have around the
communities has been a good thing and we
need to absolutely build on that so
there's lots of work being done and I
you know me I'm very candid and honest
about these things and there will be
gaps and there will be things that
haven't been gone because we are in the
middle of a global pandemic and mental
health was already a service that was
struggling before we had improve it so
they will absolutely need to be further
scrutiny done on this as we as we come
out of it for what I for one will be
keen for us to do that piece of work
just by way of me having to use the outs
of our services on behalf of the
resident three weeks ago I was really
delighted with the response it was a
Saturday morning and I've had a resident
he was in distress and around the [ __ ]
Worth and the issue was resolved within
half an hour so I know that staff out
are out there working 24 hours seven
with a juicy number so so just again I
can give reassurances but I can also
give an acceptance that there are areas
around mental health that will need you
attention House Kovac
right but I think that sort of deals
with those issues yeah possible if I
could just them yeah pick up on what
councilor heard in setting mister mental
health and I think you know from my
perspective it would be really quite
welcoming if we could hear about works
it might be possible
to be at least started before we think
about the impact of a sort of post
covert assessment if that makes sense I
think my concern was the you know the
most typical routes into accessing
mental health services is to present me
your GP into other mental health
assessment and well obviously at the
moment we'd be expecting that there's
far fewer presentations at GP practices
and then on top of that we also had some
anecdotal evidence some monks ago I
think some members may have seen at the
Guardian did a report suggesting that
Partington in Butler st. Martin's Ward
had something like the fourth highest
number of presentations per head of
population a GP practices with residents
saying that they had symptoms of
depression so I really welcome the
Mental Health Transformation Board work
is being undertaken but if it would be
possible for the next or a subsequent
scrutiny committee meeting for an update
to be provided about the progress that's
been made towards the mental health
worker I'd really welcome that if it's
possible
thank you Jeff yeah again the the
transformation work is is is starting
now and you know so yes it's a work in
progress but I have no issue at all
giving you regular updates and feedback
and welcome the import of all
counsellors really because I've had
often said it's incumbent upon all was
really to work to reduce stigma to
encourage more people to come forward
and to not wait until somebody hits
crisis so absolutely I will come back
and make sure that we give feedback
myself I counsellors later Diane Diane
got your hand up just sent me a message
saying that she's been kicked out of the
meetings that I think that might be a
false raise of a hand count so ass later
Thanks
and with councillor Williams with
already started some work within GM GM
mhm so and I think we can share that
with you with the can unite and we've
already started to look at and I like
creative ways and technology of how we
engage with the community in in the post
covert world because obviously get like
you saying normally their first point of
contact would be with you GDP and we
don't want people doing that so that
they are looking at and telephone social
distancing and Skype sort of systems to
be able to earn speak with the community
when they want to accessible so we can
share that that there's some some
information has been shared because in
writing so we can share that with the
committee so I think that would be quite
helpful for everybody yeah thanks for
that game right ok can we now move on to
the questions for the education schools
and I think we have in attendance for
the school parts councillor Hines who is
executive member for Children Services
and Jill MacGregor is a corporate
director of children's services for
education in attendance we have
councillor Carter who's a lead member
for education and Jill MacGregor who is
a corporate director of Children's
Services I think we have current samples
as well because I've seen them yeah now
she writes oh I don't know which
questions you want to pick up on on
who's going to kick off and councillor
Hynes
yes I'll I'll start thank you and thank
thank you for inviting us tonight and I
think um I'd really just like to
acknowledge I think has others have and
what an incredibly challenging and
difficult time this has been and I think
it's been an incredibly challenging time
and continues to be for all our
range really working across the council
and particularly my role as exact member
for Children Services and I'd like to
put on record if I can mag dance to to
everybody really who's working with
children with families and my thanks to
our foster carers and our thanks to to
schools really I think people have been
working around the clock to try and put
in place the right support and they've
made really important judgments in an
ever-changing landscape and I think
they've had to assess risk in a way and
the that we've never had to do before
really that's been a pace and I think
it's important really to acknowledge
that in making those decisions and the
safety and well-being and welfare of
traffic children has really been at the
heart of that decision-making process
and I just wanted to acknowledge as well
that we only got these questions and
some of them are really technical on
Friday so and there has been an effort
really over the weekend to try to pull
together the responses and I would just
like to thank Jill MacGregor and can
samples because I know they've worked
really over the weekend in Corinna as
well in pulling together our responses
I'm hopeful that we are able to respond
to those questions that'll say some of
them are very technical and and if
there's anything you know that then
follow-up wise were not able to cover
this evening then you know we will
follow that up in more detailing in
writing if that's okay and so just
moving on to the the question the first
question really that was posed to us
which was that it would be useful to
receive a short report on the
reintroduction of traffic school traffic
children back into to schools I will
hand over in a minute to councillor
Carter and just to kind of set the scene
again and I just wanted to do
knowledge again really that this has
been incredibly challenging for the
parents for children and the schools I
think lots of people understandably have
got quite a lot of anxiety I think
around the easing of the restrictions
and so we've been really trying to work
very closely in supporting schools in
making decisions and the schools
actually are the decision makers really
in terms of in terms of how they can
manage the the kind of the REO put the
wider the opening of schools obviously
schools have been open throughout and
have been working actually through
holidays bank holidays and to support
the children of of key workers and
vulnerable children in terms of the
wider reopening of schools and you know
we we've been supporting those schools
to kind of make decisions and I think
that you know is it has been a difficult
decision-making process but one which
there's been a tremendous effort around
and just kind of as a bit of a reminder
and I think probably this is well
documented and what back in May and the
prime minister made some announcements
that the schools would reopen for
nursery reception year 1 and year 6
pupils with some face to face contact
for years 10 and 12 students in Trafford
we made a recommendation initially that
schools prepare to reopen more widely on
the 10th of June and but then there were
some announcements on the 5th of June
about the r8 in the northwest so we made
a further recommendation for schools to
consider whether they needed to some
additional time really to review their
risk assessments in light of those
announcements and if so whether they
wanted to consider that wider we
opening from today so I've just turned
over now to council Carter who will just
provide you with a bit of an update
regarding the situation in terms of the
wide opening of schools and then Karina
will also take you through the questions
that have been posed on the child care
and on the government's relaxation of
key legislation in relation to yoke
Snoopy's and then she'll hand back to me
to respond to the children in care
question and then we'll cover cover the
best so if I can hand over to you Karina
thank you from the pressure cast yes so
obviously as you know today is the day
that we have all schools and we do know
that all schools are opening today to
accept wider numbers of children by the
end of last Friday even though we said
to schools it would be okay to wait till
today
71 schools did open primary schools did
open last week to take in more children
um as of Friday we had two thousand and
six children in schools and we gave
ourselves a bit longer and we gave
schools a bit longer because we said as
an authority we would check every
schools risk assessment and that's
because the health and safety like
legality lies with the authority so
there was a team of people working on
that last week to make sure that they're
all the assessments were checked and we
also needed to have a meeting with the
unions which happened last Tuesday so we
all along we said to schools do what
you're comfortable with so whilst we've
said we were completely relaxed and
would advise schools to open today as I
say 71 did open last week I don't know
if Karen's got data from today how many
children that we've had in or is it too
early to say yeah it's too early to say
at the moment Karina there's always a
day's lag so we'll have that data
tomorrow but you know we we will
definitely see a huge spike in terms of
the numbers
just because we know that the remaining
schools would would be open and equally
the secondaries would begin to open to
their year 10 in year 12 cohorts and
relax week we see a significant shift
today it could give us the figures
absolutely no that's that's absolutely
fine we can do that
I think they can select and we are
expecting to see some sort of variation
throughout the thorah as well as to you
know just to catherine said about parent
confidence being quite low we certainly
know there's more demand in what we see
is to south of the Burrow than the north
of the borough so but the figures I'll
be able to show that when we get them
yeah I think I think knowing what you
know for the first day kind of thing in
Trafford it'd be useful to have that
data of children then we can compare
that we go sorry Queen I was going to
say I think it's worth as well council
acting and recognizing that every day
will possibly be different as well and
because clearly obviously every school
they may have a roted system and they
may have a day where they close for a
clean and where staff will have their
planning preparation and assessment and
their PPA entitlement and so I think we
will kind of see a fluctuation over time
dependent on how schools roll out the
wider reopening and as they move through
the days and the weeks and but I'll
certainly you know we will certainly
begin to get a better grip I think on
the position of the the number of pupils
from now so that's the reopening of the
schools are you taking the next one
Karina yeah I'll take it about the Chao
minders and obviously our earliest
provision and PVI settings
Oh No I've got question but I think it's
oh no we did John ma'am I was out with
the last one you know David it was just
going on from the last bit of discussion
about the numbers of children attending
schools right and I think a good yeah a
good point was made I think we're gonna
get some data and I think remember who
was making a really good point about the
north and south which I think really
plays into the issues of children have
the same advantages of some of the
children and similarly the issue of
access to digital technology which
enables them to continue their schooling
when not at school so you know the more
data we can have which gives us insight
to to to that I'm sure you'll be very
interested also in will be interested I
think John you'll be aware as well some
of the schools just not really a quick
to take very many more children you know
some of the scores in older buildings or
schools that have already have a lot of
keyword for vulnerable children just
aren't going to be able to expand as
much as they'd like to if I could just
completely endorse up to Corina I
visited both Broad Oak and National
Mersey High School's last Friday prior
to those schools receiving their
students today and it really is
surprising when you put a two meter
distance between desks you have to see
it to believe it I know it's we can say
these things but when you see it in a
classroom you realize just how
restrictive I think it's also worth
noting that the DfE have released some
additional guidance literally this
afternoon where they're advocating the
wider return for additional year groups
on top of those key year groups with
talks about today for primary school if
if schools are in a position they've got
the capacity the space and staffing to
accommodate those additional year groups
and so we'll wait and see how that
impacts
I think particularly on that on our
junior schools I think that's
potentially where we may see an increase
in those children outside of the vo6 and
what we are making it clear to the
schools is that they must absolutely not
compromise their ability to provide a
placement for children or key workers
and vulnerable pupils you know this has
to be on top of and if I could you just
come in a sorry apologies and counteract
and I can't find but raise your hand but
just to reiterate that and as well as
the provision in terms of being able to
provide for children of key workers
vulnerable children that is data that
we've been required to report on to DFA
and we have been tracking and tracing
those those numbers and having a
proactive reach out to approach both
from a children's social care and a
schools point of view for the very
reasons that you're articulating about
what does that mean in terms of further
disadvantage and loss learning with the
overall approach that we have taken has
been very much that we need to
understand each individual school
circumstances how many pupils that they
have the makeup of those pupils as well
as their physical building and context
and location which is why we've said our
approach has been very much on a risk
assessment based model and because it's
really important that we take account of
all of those different factors in order
to be able to put the right support in
place yeah that makes complete sense
yeah okay
Karina are you going to go on to the
child minders right so the guidance that
came out and and to to just reiterate
what Karen said that this afternoon it
was the 30th peak of guidance it's been
issued by the DfE since this crisis
started so time to keep on top of
everything's been really difficult but
when the guidance came out around Chao
minders and schools obviously we know
children have to stay in the bubbles and
so the guidance did say that the
children should only attend one setting
where possible and so that children
should be looked after in their bubbles
and obviously I think probably an
unintended consequence of bass is it's
meant that it's made life really
difficult for child minders who would
quite often pick up from numerous
schools and certainly would would not
just keep children in the bubbles so as
of last week we did have 99 child
minders were open out of we've got 230
39 child minders in traffic 99 of those
child minders were open last week but 30
of them that were open had no children
and yet again this reflects the fact
that parents don't feel confident enough
to send their children back yet so I
think one of the things I've really
liked was the committee is about whether
you can make a recommendation from this
meeting to allow the LA to work with the
sector to try and reopen more out of
school settings and more child minders
because you know we'd like to do that
and we know they want to do it as well I
think a lot of us have had
correspondence from out of school clubs
but you know there's a real worried that
a lot of this provision won't be here by
the time we all get back up and running
again there any questions yeah
councillor knew the actual issues that
I've been contacted about with regards
this is that it's the actual at the
schools that are preventing child
minders from collecting so it's putting
parents under unbelievable amount of
pressure because you know many are
working shifts and some of these
children have been in those settings
before they actually went to school so
it's like for instance in the situation
that I've been contacted contacted by
and the child is 8 years old and he's
now this Charmander has looked after
this child throughout lockdown the
child's gone to to school and
now she's unable to actually collect for
Charles which you know it's just
creating so many issues for people so
I'm wondering if there's anything that I
can go back to her with you know sort of
from this just sort of reassured all
that you know things are gonna be
changing
Karen yeah thank you for that counseling
you I think certainly when we've had our
meetings with heads you know they have
raised this issue and I've tried to
manage the risk that six with as Karina
isthat around the bubbles managing the
risks it sits outside of school and as
the children actually come into school
and and the potential for any cross
infection etc exception and we do have
our early years petite board actually
tomorrow and we've also got a meeting
with primary cluster Leeds on Wednesday
so this is something that we can discuss
it but both of those forums I think
counseling you because it affects both
really I think you'd be helpful to
understand as well which schools were
talking about because I'm aware of one
where there's been an issue but I'm not
aware of where else it's happening I
think that would be helpful because we
can do a little bit of work and dialogue
with the heads to try and find a
solution really about how we can support
the families and the child minders as
well but it is I think it is
unfortunately where you've got schools
who are having to major risk they're
completing risk assessments they're
obviously getting an awful lot of
guidance from DfE which is talking about
the single setting obviously some of the
information that's been presented by
public health as well and but I think
certainly this is this is part of the
dialogue this is the start of the
dialogue so we will continue to work
with the sector to see how we can look
at what the possible solutions are and
just to reiterate in terms of trying to
seek solutions Karen and I were in the
meeting on Friday with the Regional
schools commissioner and amongst others
and we're very much making
representations about the confusion not
the confusion was actually the guidance
isn't always the most helpful but the
sorts of circumstances that you're
talking about and not least recognizing
that we have a real sustainability
the issue in terms of the sector so I
think Karen's suggestions about there's
a couple of forums where we can look at
what some of our local approaches might
be while still working within the
framework of the guidance is probably
really really helpful because if we
absolutely recognize the need to have a
flexible wraparound childcare offer and
conversely or perversely if you like
cope it means that it's even more
important that we have some flexibility
but trying to manage that from an
infection control point of view and
saying it must look like this takes away
some of that flexibility so I think it's
really important that we have ongoing
dialogue that looks at what some of our
local solutions might be whilst
recognising the need for sustainability
just from a public health point of view
as well one of the things I'm going
forward is really to make sure that
people are honest about the arrangements
that they have and actually by having
stability a stable arrangement is much
safer even if I mean the child might
need to acknowledge that they might need
to self isolate if there was an
infection but actually having that
knowledge of what's happening and being
able to have a stable relationship is
much much better for the children and
it's better for actually the infection
control because then we do at least we
know what's going on if we try and if we
try and be too prescriptive things go
underground and you just don't find out
what's happening and that's very risky
so it isn't that how we manage that
support okay any other questions on this
topic I mean I think if anything that we
as a committee can do I think just to
support the flexible approach we're
trying to take really yeah you know in
schools to will amend their risk
assessments but you know we really don't
want to see the sector to go under Dave
and I think an authority we need to give
them as much support as we can I think
the other thing I've been asked if like
up around this is that we will see an
increase in the number of children who
will be eligible
for the two-year-old funding as the
disadvantaged gap grows in the general
population more children will now become
eligible for that free funding of places
it to so just to make the committee
aware of that should we move on to the
next question which is a relaxation of
the key legislation and reasonable
endeavors yeah yeah I think what I want
to first of all say is eh CP completion
times are currently at 73% which is an
increase from 61% to the last time this
data was collected was that data
collected that that was actually part of
our send to data so that was kind of
when we formally and provided that data
for publishing and yes that would have
been prior to prior to the pan yeah
prior to the pandemic in terms of this
end to data but we do monitor it on a
monthly basis counselor Acton so all
decisions for new requests are being
made in the six weeks time take time to
scale and no exceptions have been
applied so far in completing the plans
so actually I think that probably puts
us in one of the top of GMC a now from
we were way way at the bottom a couple
years ago but you know that team's done
a really brilliant job so the whole it's
business as usual all the panels are
operating with the same frequency
regularity and representation across
education health and social care all
assessments are being completed by the
ED Sykes and the other professionals are
working online or via the telephone
depending on what the family want and
our peripatetic services are well for
not
working in schools they're working as
they can with in line with risk
assessments so so for the actual the eh
CP work I think that's just everything's
just carrying on
there's been no no lapse in that okay
yeah so okay can I just check then there
hasn't been any relaxation of the
legislation basically come in very
similar to the adult easements act under
covert legislation there have been
amendments to the children act and the
adoption act 2004 one of the things that
we've done in a similar way to our adult
colleagues is absolutely outline what
those different freedom and
flexibilities can be the circumstances
in which we might have to enact those
freedom and flexibilities not just in
relation to the SE ND agenda but in
terms of adoption fostering requirements
which children we can place we put all
of that into an assurance document that
is included where it will be signed off
through and the agency decision-maker
through myself as corporate DCs all
indeed members and very much we have
operated following and maintaining
business as usual processes so we know
one of the questions later on that we
will cool to is about visits to children
and some of the freedom and flexibility
about visiting less often we have not
enacted that and similarly in the center
gender we have room panels in the same
way and Karen will give you the detail
of us yeah just just to say
counteraction just to make it clear yeah
the panels and the decision-making
process hasn't changed at all and
obviously in terms of the actual recent
when Devers and some of the being able
to meet the needs that I'd or that they
meet the requirements that are
identified in the plans
that's where at the moment we're scoping
out any of those decisions that schools
have happened
if there are challenges around meeting
the children's needs perhaps that they
they can't achieve because of some of
the issues you know that the pandemic
has presented for schools
we're actually collating that
information today I think is the
deadline for that and so that we can be
really clear what we're communicated to
san'ko's into schools is everything
around the reasonable endeavors what the
legislation actually means what it means
for the children and the pupils that are
in their schools and in their care and
that's being fed back to us and then to
kind of close the loop if you like we're
then going to be contacting every senko
in all of the settings to actually have
a conversation around any any use of
reasonable endeavors how they are
continuing to meet the needs of the
children are there any problems have you
have you worked in in co-production with
families and parents have you have you
had that conversation and dialogue just
to make sure that we are satisfied that
schools are doing everything within
their power to continue to make
effective provision for those children
with additional needs questions okay can
I just say them I think it's really
reassuring that you know you've not had
to relax you know the legislation
because these are very vulnerable and I
think if there is a need to do that I
think it you know members really need to
know the supports had to go online as
you would imagine so the sensory
impairment service and the speech
therapy have been sending packs home for
parents and at each of the death checks
in with the schools on a weekly basis
and there is some provision like we have
some children who are doing Lego therapy
well evidently they can't do that at the
moment
but you know that same level of support
is being delivered just not in the
traditional way we've actually asked as
well for some detail around the
therapies that have been offered for
children with additional needs just so
that we've got a really clear stare on
their planning for recovery and what the
therapies will look like as we as we
move forward just so that we can see how
the brain ball being brought back into
line is more and more children come back
into schools so can we now move on to
children in care so thanks yeah yes and
just before I do move on entirely into
children in care I just wanted to
mention actually that and the the
children's scrutiny committee and had
presented a task and finish report who
to the executive and some time we're
going it was just because it's related
to the previous and the previous
question just to kind of mention really
that we have got a response to that and
we've had that ready for for some time
now but because of the the changes who
are operating lately during during the
pandemic and we've not had that
opportunity to present our response to
that task and and finish and but I did
just want to say really that whilst you
know this is far from ideal and it's not
what we would have wanted and actually
it probably does give us an opportunity
and some to kind of update our response
really in light of what you know is it
is obviously happening with the kovat
and to really kind of reflect on the
fact that you know this is a priority
for us and it's going to continue to be
a priority for us and that I think
is this counselor Lam alluded to earlier
on I think it was you know we've got to
kind of be really mindful as you know
that we don't want that gap to to open
up and become more wide and so you know
this is something that we will make sure
that we've got our focus on and perhaps
it is something that we can include in
our response to the task and finish and
but yeah just to kind of make that point
really and so in terms of the questions
around children in care I think Jill as
kind of already said mainly and that
that we haven't reduced the frequency of
Social Work visits to children in care
during the pandemic and this is
something that you know I receive
regular updates on Jill and I are in you
know kind of constant communication
really about this and it is a priority
and that we remain in touch with
children in care and social workers have
kind of needed probably to be flexible
and and to be creative in some respects
in terms of how they carry out those
visits and we are carrying out as many
face-to-face visits as possible some of
the visits have been carried out by
videoconferencing where it's been
necessary to do that but social workers
have also kind of been creative in terms
of trying to make sure that they're able
to speak to to the children when they're
carrying out the visits and you know to
try in and sometimes to kind of
spiritual in the moment if you can and
as well as be continuing to carry out
the visits and with at least the same
frequency as before if not in some cases
increased frequency where that's been
necessary and what we've tried to ensure
happens is the quality of those visits
is maintained so there has been a kind
of focus on this we've had weekly
updates through the performance
reporting process and they've also been
two full audits that have been carried
out really I would say to ensure that
that quality of visit has has been
maintained and we've also wanted to make
sure that the experience of children is
is reflected in and understood and the
voice of the child during the pandemic
has you know this kind of being heard
and so in terms of assurances and
safeguarding again this obviously is
something that is incredibly important
and something that you know we have been
working very closely with our partners
and at rapid safeguarding partnership
and so in in addition to those measures
that are kind of already mentioned and
we've also developed a clear system of
contact and liaison with our schools and
where vulnerable children who should be
in school but haven't been attending and
we've we've had a sometimes a daily call
with the schools and the first response
team and which has an included decision
making really around and whether or not
and some different from the school or it
might be some different service and kind
of has had an increased contact with the
family and I think this has been
something actually that's been quite
positive and in terms of the development
of our relationship with the schools I
think we've kind of had a an incredibly
close relationship with the schools
around this and a much more open
dialogue so we've kind of talked about
what support schools have needed and
they've they've been speaking to us and
because you know it's it's absolutely
the case that quite often schools will
know children and better than anybody
know we've been a
to kind of build on that relationship
which has been very very positive and
it's something that we hope to
strengthen really as those restrictions
are re used and as I say we've been also
working with other partners with the
police and I think we've got concerns as
either authorities and up and down the
country have got really around those
children and families that perhaps
emerging issues have started to arise
what perhaps that we haven't necessarily
been aware of prior to the lockdown and
you know it's it because children
haven't necessarily presented in the
usual settings you know they haven't had
always the same kind of presentation in
in some of the health settings that GPS
and the surgeries and obviously lots of
children haven't been in school we have
been concerned as I say as other
authorities that perhaps there are
children that we haven't known about and
likewise we know that that there may
have been the increases in domestic
violence in families and so we have been
trying to work with the police to make
sure that the incidents are like noodles
at the earliest opportunity and we're
also planning around as a restrictions
do start to lift you know there may be a
surging referrals and making sure that
we've got found in place to to kind of
to deal with all of that and and as I
said working with the traffic
safeguarding partnership really to get
messages out and to communicate where we
know that people are presenting and and
to communicate with people online as
well through various different forums
really and so and I think that covers
that question is is bad can I bring in
councilor Thompson yeah thanks Dave
two minutes of these new cases that
might arise there in terms of our
overall demand we've seen must've crews
at times by as much as 30% so if you
looked at that up lifting then that
would be a significant increase having
said that as you know in 2019 our demand
and the numbers of children that we're
receiving a social care so this was
probably too high for Trafford so if you
purely looked crossways it doesn't look
as as great as you think but we have
seen some of our demand particularly
from our health art nurse so community
health settings last week for example we
only had two referrals from a community
health setting such as a health visitor
we haven't seen the same level of
referrals or contacts from schools but
as council Hinds has already said the
level of contacts that we're having with
schools is taking almost something of a
different route so we've done quite a
lot of work to say don't forget to
follow the normal routes the normal
pathways just because you're having a
conversation about a child that you
should think should be in school if
you've got a worry that means they need
additional support from children's
social care you need to make the
referral in the same way so we've done a
lot of proactive work not only through
the strategic safeguarding partnership
but through the the meetings that we had
in this period with schools so it really
feels that we're in a position where the
data and the horizon scanning and the
prediction of the demand feels really
quite unreliable because we've generally
seen police referrals stay the same but
from our other partners particularly
health in schools schools being the
second biggest repair have really quite
reduced so potentially it would subvert
e percent increase in demand what I
think it won't be as much as that
because of some of the work that we've
got ongoing no other questions no can we
now move on to
and the next one really advantage and
vulnerable schoolchildren they've been a
lot evidence and media internet since a
lockdown
they've been a bigger negative impact on
those children so yeah what action we
can take really well I mean it's it's an
emerging picture I think at the moment
Dave isn't it and we won't actually be
able to see the disadvantage gap till we
get all children back in school but I
think most people will have read that
Guardian article saying maybe the last
ten years of trying to close that gap
might have disappeared over this time so
it's a really really big issue for
everybody what I can say is our children
are 251 children who've got a HCP plans
we've got her to Nate five three social
workers and we've got 237 vulnerable of
the children and we know that those
children have been prioritized in terms
of accessing school places and that
they've been monitored and another shout
out here to schools for the free school
meal vouchers that schools have been
absolutely excellent in ensuring that
all and all of the children entitled to
have had those vouchers and first of all
for the Easter holidays then than the
may holidays and now you know there's a
national campaign to get matching for
the summer holidays as well so that's
been really good the work that's been
going on has been around home learning
and and giving people access to it we've
also seen haven't we the problems being
the digital disadvantage we're calling
it where children don't have access to
ID at home and I know that's the next
question but as an as an authority we've
been encouraging schools to access the
BBC bite-sized and the Nash Oak National
Academy which is what the government
have set up to do online lessons we've
seen lots of packs of materials
delivered children's homes
this means some zoom lessons and weekly
calls to parents and children to check
in and I think schools have really
really put lots and lots of emphasis on
the vulnerable children the bigger issue
is the children that haven't attended
and you know we know that that has been
a real problem for many schools really
to get those children back in so I don't
know if Karen wants to add anything now
I you know I think I think you've
covered most things Karina I think we
are all very aware of the challenge of
the lost learning and we've created some
additional subgroups with a range of
representatives on it including from
schools and then across all services and
in different parts of the organization
really where we're focusing on teaching
and learning and that recovery
curriculum we're calling it and I think
we're going to do a lot of work around
reading and vocabulary because we know
that the word gap is going to increase
significantly and without addressing
that that's going to impact on all parts
of the curriculum and so there's an
awful lot of work going on around that
and obviously there's a lot of work
across GM as well at the moment so we're
linking in with with other parts of GM
and certainly linking in with Andy
Burnham and Lucy Powell who are think of
being and really want to be sighted on
what we're going to do around bridging
that gap as much as we can and that
might include summer offer and and you
know and then further down the line with
living with kovat and also you know just
just think we know that the education
endowment fund rules are going to be
producing materials which we're going to
encourage schools to tap in so there's
lots of catch-up and intervention
programs those rapid and improvement
programs which schools can adapt for
their learners what we are saying to
schools is we've just got to get the
children ready to learn before they can
actually learn so there's a big focus on
the mental health we're very aware of
the fact that this is almost like
children will go come back to school
almost having experienced trauma and
we've really got to consider attachment
and trauma based and challenges that
children might have
the Educational Psychology service are
going to be supporting schools in
developing that really we've kind of got
a two-pronged attack really where
obviously we'll have the clinical and
the health side of things addressing
some of those needs
but what we're also trying to do is
equip schools to be able to be and to be
able to handle some of the challenges
themselves so we don't need to get to
that and a referral route really so
there'll be a lot of working in getting
schools mentally mental health champions
and so on and so forth but just
understanding the position of children
and and getting them ready to learn
before we we kind of move them um I
think there's a big push for
particularly some of the children who
will be going into year one in September
to actually go back and do two terms
worth of the early years framework
because they will have missed that and
they'll be absolutely not ready to it to
to take on the challenge of a year one
curriculum so there's lots of work
across the GM and early education needs
in how again we sort of try and mitigate
some of the gaps that there are very
young children will have experienced as
well I mean the last question is the
mental health one really and
particularly and I know we're running
out of time of it now but that you know
the health healthy young minds service
seems to have a a long waiting list and
no longer upsetting new referrals I
don't know whether that is correct or
not I know I was just going to say that
is really information that that we've
been given that they're not accepting
referrals and and we've also been told
that they haven't got a really long
waiting list now they've actually only
got 11 young people who were on their
way to lists and all of those 11 have
actually got telephone assessments
booked for June or July and they've
managed to clear their waiting lists
down from 105 it was at the end of March
and but that's been over the kovat
period and I guess it isn't that they're
not accepting new refills I think it's
that they've had far fewer referrals
than they normally would during this
period which has probably enabled them
to to clear some of their waiting list
they've also I think because they are
able to do some of their work by a
telephone consultation they've been able
to perhaps work with with more people
than they perhaps might otherwise have
done which is aided them in in reducing
that waiting list and they have still
been offering some face-to-face
appointment particularly with those
people who kind of present I think that
that the UQ and if they present
certainly it's a tiny and but they have
been doing some of their group work it's
been done via video conferencing as well
so obviously I think as you know again
as restrictions start to ease and you
need to be really mindful that actually
you know that that service is able to to
cope if there is a surge in demand and
likewise with our community mental
health teams I think Karen's already
covered really you know the the as as we
do emerge from the restrictions now we
need to make sure that we have got those
plans in place to deal with and you know
where there may be trauma but I think to
take councillor Williams's point from
earlier on you know what is happening
now because we do know that there are
children and young people who are
struggling now in you know in lockdown
with issues impacting their mental
health and I know there has been a
really big effort by and some of the
online support services really who've
being and the main one that springs to
my mind really to to kind of support and
to advertise really the support that
they offer to young people affects fun
did that offer up to I think up to the
age of 19 from 16 I think it was
previously and such and they've been
trying very much to encourage people to
use and the online resources really
because being really conscious of the
fact that isolation has massively
impacted the mental health of children
and young people and the son tried to
kind of come off that as quickly as I
can but if there are any additional
questions you know we would be happy to
pick those up and as we said you need to
do that you know a later date we've run
out of time you know I think the only
point that I would probably make from
what instead is you know far fewer
referrals through this pandemic doesn't
mean to say that the problems go away
you know we're going to get to be doing
thinking about how we're going to and I
think just too often committee some
reassurance we have a dedicated were
extreme both in terms of response and
recovery around emotional well-being
mental health and whilst formal if you
like some of you traditional services
such as comes have seen that reduction
in referrals things like couth where you
can do self-referrals online referrals
telephone consultations and we've seen
an increase in those sorts of services
so we're already proactively working
with commissioners and with some of our
third sector providers to try and make
sure that there's a really comprehensive
range of office we're currently doing an
in-depth mapping exercise about what is
the totality of the offer which services
for which groups including which angel
is which sorts of criteria of issue that
they respond to so that we can
absolutely target responses in terms of
where they're are perceived or actual
gaps in terms of that emerging and
changing needs because we're incredibly
mindful that
and some of our children and you young
people and our families that are
normally quite resourceful normally
quite resilient everybody will have been
touched by this experience so you need
to both anticipate take the learning
from experience elsewhere and harness
the expertise across the whole system
right well I think that brings us to the
close really of the meeting well I just
want a few minutes with the members of
the committee so for everybody else can
I really thank you all for coming along
and answering those questions the
executive members and the offices and
Helena so thank you all
you know you thank you you didn't next
job in very difficult I'm sorry I don't
actually know how to leave all else
fails Yeah right
I suppose it's what the you know how we
sort of analyzed you know the answers
that we've got to the questions that we
deal with you know and what comment we
may want to to make and and any
Betterman Dacians that we'd like to make
but I think we need colleagues we are
we're having about time now because we
do we are to to finish in a few minutes
so and I think we have a a panel meeting
at the agenda panel meeting this week
but what I would ask members if they
feel that some questions need food
you know further information and those
that might have not just questions but
maybe recommendations it would be useful
to hear from you over the next few days
to see what they might be
and obviously it's been a long meeting
and two hours is a long time on on zoom
a dude's in real life but you know I
think we have a lot of information so I
what I suggest is that we digest that
and if you've got any thoughts about the
meeting or recommendations that we might
want to follow you know even if it's
just to you know know the responses and
thankfully and the officers but actually
today so and yes Denise yeah yeah and I
think how agenda setting meeting is
actually on Wednesday thank you it's not
giving in people a lot of time really to
digest such as such a large amounts of
information
yeah I mean I think we we don't have to
do sort of Russian response but I think
while sitting fresh in people's mind you
know if you any any member feels that
you know you want to raise some issues
or you know recommendations that's come
out of the meeting that would be and
we'll try and collate that as quickly as
possibly can I mean our next meeting
anyway it's a first of July so we've got
a set
agenda that CEO that hides maman
it's a last item on this agenda I think
we did talk about you know the butcher's
having a budget reports and looking at
that and all that you know through
through the pandemic there's a lot of
different issues financial issues that
you know been impacted on this pandemic
so I I think that's probably the main
one I have a public would suggest it if
there's any other hanging all but issues
you know that would be the main item you
know I'm in your hands anybody got any
thoughts but there but it would end
there yeah okay yeah councillor congi
just in terms of issues for the next
meeting and there's obviously been a lot
of radical changes to our active
transport network and I wondered if it
was worth and let's just go sings bash
at the next meeting
active transport the yeah the 8:56 cycle
a right yeah he she's verging Barrington
Road and altering ham and things will be
lots of others yeah that would be useful
members are happy to look at that yeah
what we do next isn't it yeah do you
feel that there's anything yeah sorry
this councillor lamb and council about
it yeah thanks David it was only just to
match some counterintuitive but just
following on from Denise's comment I
think it might be useful to get comments
in fairly quickly now because I mean all
information we've listened to its it's
easy to sort of forget a lot of it and
what I think might be helpful and
certainly one thing I'll be doing is
just maybe thinking about you
what were the one two most three things
that really struck us during all that
inflammation because we probably don't
have time to go through all these
responses in the great detail would
probably ask you know end up asking more
questions but I think that for most of
us that probably one or two maybe three
things that have really come out I think
of ADA's point about mental health I
think that also is something that struck
me for example
preparedness for what Karen sample was
talking about something that all hits a
lot of children and actually all our
population in the months and months to
to come so you know that for example is
something that's struck me I think if we
get our comments in on those sorts of
lines and waltz we don't fairly quickly
which you know might be useful then - I
mean if members could do that you know
really welcome that you know so if
you're happy to do that then that'd be
great counselor birthday oh hi thank you
David and yeah I don't take him too much
time I do think it's quite important
just as a very tiny thing of every
meeting just to keep an eye on the
figures to trace isolate it I think
which is you know going to in depth all
the time but just to really have a kind
of look at the figures as time goes by
on those because is going to be really
important keeping you know the
population safe so if we could agree to
that that would be great
yeah I think we should do that and I
think there was a number of other issues
where we we wanted this similar kind of
thing really you know just to be kept
updated and you know we can ask for that
within you know a report that we might
you know that comes from this meeting
yeah and I think there was something
about child minders as well on that that
we could you know make the
recommendation
I think can I just say Dave yeah yeah I
think that the asking is to make a
recommendation about child minders and I
know Karina's just said flexible but I
think it's something that we would need
to have more information on as such
because to make that recommendation
might be going against various things so
for example a child might and I
understand the problem about a child
minder taking children to school and
collecting them it's just that some
children will be vulnerable anyway for
example one in four children have asthma
or one in three I think so it's also for
how do you protect some children to
their not go to school
are they kept at home and it really
seems that risk assessment to me is huge
yeah I mean I think it's something we
need to think about I mean what what but
what she actually said was you know the
la the local authority work with the
center itself I think she was asking
about it's giving them the flexibility
wasn't it yeah if I remember rightly and
I just think yes but I think we need to
be very careful maybe we maybe we should
ask for a bit more information
yeah I'd be happier they're the kind of
things really that you know if members
can you know just shut your thoughts
down you know it might just be one line
or it might be paragraph
yeah so so I would are we happy to do
that yeah you know we'll try and pull it
together and then formulate some kind of
you know report from what we've heard
tonight
so with that everybody's happy anything
else on the agenda Alex there's nothing
else had they gone home John yeah
there's nothing else on the the agenda
items to be covered the next time but I
don't get you're focusing mainly on
those that were raised in the meeting
this time yeah that's great can I thank
you all you know your patience and your
questions and everything I think you
know it's really helpful to have those
kind of questions so that we can
actually probe rather than just having
presentations you know which we know a
lot of the information with this at
least we found out a lot of detail and I
think they questioning around you know
the relaxation of some of the you know
the services it's useful to know you
know watch they happen to that so Oh
[Music]
so thanks thanks very much and I won't
say have a safe journey home with your
home so goodbye have a nice evening
[Music]